AND, HEY,
YOU'RE CHRIS ROCK!
- IT'S DAVE CHAPPELLE,
BUT CLOSE ENOUGH.
- WHERE ARE YOU GUYS GOING?
- WELL, DANGLE'S
NOT FEELING WELL,
SO I'M TAKING HIM
TO THE DOCTOR.
- WHAT'S WRONG, DANGLE?
- ACTUALLY,
IT'S MY PENIS.
- WHAT'S THAT?
[unzips pants]
all: EW.
- WHEN I PEE-PEE,
IT BURNS LIKE HELL.
I HAVE WHAT'S KNOWN
AS A VENEREAL DISEASE.
- HOW DID YOU GET IT?
- FROM (BLEEP).
I GOT SO MUCH PUPPET ASS,
IT COULD BE FROM ANYWHERE.
- WHAT'S THE SICKNESS CALLED?
- I'M NOT SURE, ROBERT.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE GOING
TO THE DOCTOR.
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT KINDS
OF PENIS SICKNESSES OUT THERE.
ISN'T THAT RIGHT, Q-TIP?
- THAT'S RIGHT, DAVE,
ALL KINDS.
♪ SEX ISN'T WRONG
BUT YOU GOTTA BE RIGHT ♪
♪ IF YOU'RE HITTING THE SHEETS ♪
♪ THEN WRAP IT UP TIGHT ♪
♪ LISTEN UP, KIDS,
'CAUSE I AIN'T JOKIN' ♪
♪ ONE BAD DECISION ♪
♪ YOUR (BLEEP) WILL BE SMOKIN' ♪
♪ YOU'LL CATCH A V.D.
BUT DON'T TAKE IT FROM ME ♪
[traditional French music]
♪ ♪
[sizzling]
OH, HELLO, DAVE CHAPPELLE,
HAVEN'T SEEN YOU FOR A WHILE.
WHAT'S IT BEEN,
TWO MONTHS?
- DIRTY MOTHER(BLEEP).
OH, HERE COME THE CRABS.
[bright Latin music]
♪ ♪
♪ THE CRABS ♪
- ♪ OH, YES ♪
both: ♪ THE CRAB, THE CRABS ♪
- OLE!
- THIS NIGGA'S A FREAK.
[upbeat music]
♪ ♪
♪ I'M THE HERPES,
THE HERPES ♪
SEE YOU IN HELL,
MOTHER(BLEEP).
OOH, BABY,
I LIKE IT RAW.
- OH, GOSH.
- WOW, LIFE IS HARD.
- NAH, IT'S NOT, LISA.
ALL RIGHT, LOOK,
IF YOU JUST REMEMBER
TO KEEP YOUR GENITALS
OUT OF HARM'S WAY,
DON'T CHASE MONEY,
AND REFRAIN FROM LITTERING,
YOU'LL BE A WINNER.
[kids cheer]
- Q-TIP, TAKE US HOME!
COME ON, KIDS!
- ♪ IT'S A V.D. DAY ♪
- ♪ V.D. DAY,
A V.D. DAY ♪
- ♪ IT'S A V.D. DAY ♪
- ♪ V.D. DAY,
A V.D. DAY ♪